[Music]
alright guys so I told you I was gonna
have new reviews for brand new video
games pretty soon and I picked up dead
space 3 last week Tuesday at midnight
and I've since beaten it even got this
really awesome poster that's like so big
can't even fit in the frame know before
I get in depth about dead space 3 I'll
let you know that I did really enjoy the
first two games and I was excited about
Dead Space 3 but at the same time I was
kind of apprehensive in the same way
that aim about movies once a series
starts to get so long to the point where
so many sequels are coming out and
you're like I really hope this doesn't
suck now for anyone who doesn't know the
story of the dead space games I'll sum
it up really quick basically there's
this thing called the marker it's this
big monolith similar to the Space
Odyssey monolith except it's really
twisty and pointy and this thing has the
ability to spread this disease amongst
humankind people turn into these giant
bug like creatures they decay to the
point where they're unrecognizable and
they just want to go around and kill
anything in sight now these games take
place in a very dystopian futuristic
world generally always in space the main
character Isaac Clarke is a lowly
engineer he's just a grunt he's no one
special and he's always in the wrong
place at the wrong time similar to John
McClane this guy knows everything and
anything about fixing ships and by now
he knows quite a bit about these
creatures known as the Necromorphs
there's also a religious cult that for
some reason seems to think that mankind
needs to turn into these creatures so
they can go back to the top of the food
chain and somehow get closer to God and
in this game he's drugged back into the
fray because a woman that he knows is
involved with it and he wants to make
sure she's safe now that's cliched and
to be honest the entire story behind the
dead space games isn't the most
impressive thing and especially with
Dead Space 3 the weakest part of this
game is probably the story elements to
it but nevertheless the reason I play
these games is because they're visceral
entertainment at its best it's great
sci-fi horror it's great sci-fi action
and it's a lot of fun and in my opinion
Dead Space 3 follow suit with the first
two games very well right off the bat
this game has one of the best opening
sequences I've ever seen in a game it
was incredible and completely unexpected
and I can't wait for you guys to
experience that opening because it's one
of the coolest openings I've
played the best way I can describe this
game to you is it's basically the movie
the thing on acid it takes place almost
entirely on an ice planet and a lot of
people were curious about how that was
gonna be because most of the previous
two games were in ships in space this
game does start out in a ship and it
kind of gets you into the game and lets
you experience it kind of like you did
in the first two and then it throws you
into this ice planet and it's awesome
you can't tell where these things are
they pop out of the ground they come at
you through the whiteout of the snow
it's really fun and you actually get
some really intense jump moments where I
was actually okay that was a little
disturbing in fact there is one moment
in this game that truly actually gave me
goosebumps there's a scene where Isaac
has to go in this cavern underground and
he can only see with the flashlight
that's on his plasma cutter so we're
shining it around and all of a sudden he
comes across this little tiny group of
these creatures that are just huddled
around something and then they just turn
and stare you for like ten seconds and
they just keep staring and then they
just jump Isaac it would actually it
really scared me I was like that was
that was good job game developers
speaking of them visceral did a really
good job with this game in particular
the graphics oh my god this game looks
amazing the world of this game is
perhaps the most impressive element of
it just to fully-realized environment
that Isaac and these other characters
inhabit there were times in the game
where there were no enemies around where
I would just stop and just look around
because it was so impressive to look at
it has the same problem the first game
had where there are certain control
elements where if you press something
just the wrong way you like lose all
your health or something or you use your
health and you're not supposed to and so
it's creatures everywhere but you need
your health but you can't use your
health because you actually press the
button the wrong way when you want it to
use your Kinesis but hope you just
refilled your health whoops now I don't
have the health I needed later that
happens a few times in this game but
once you focus on the controls and get
used to them it's a piece of cake there
are two big gameplay switches in this
game compared to the first two number
one is at the bench the place where in
the first two games you would upgrade
your weapons then there was a safe and
you could buy things at a store you
could buy new weapons you could sell
your weapons or whatever this game does
not have the store it all completely
does away with it in this game you
actually scavenge and hunt for parts to
assemble your own guns you can make and
craft your own gun in any way you want
to and the other two games that were
crates throughout the whole game and you
could stomp on them and they're the
items in them this game has that as well
except in the past it was always health
or am
or something along those lines in this
game in regards to animal there's only
one item and it's called ammo clip you'd
get that you get as many of them as you
can and you can add it to any weapon you
want to which is pretty cool since you
can't buy things at a store and you have
to hunt and scavenge for parts
many of these crates have parts in them
like a circuit you may need for a gun or
this gel that you can use to fix your
suit or whatever the problem I had with
that was let's say I'm in the middle of
a giant boss battle there's this giant
bug trying to rip my head off there's
all these crates everywhere great I
really need health and ammo right now oh
but guess what I just found some gel in
one of these crates great I can do my
hair while I fight this giant bug who's
trying to ram his giant hand up my butt
and so that got a little tiresome after
a while because the crates would have
random items in them you want it to be
helped he wanted to be animal but oh I
got some gel for my gun that I can't use
right now thanks game so in that aspect
it got annoying but it was kind of cool
to make your own weapons the other
gameplay element that seriously switches
things up is the addition of co-op now a
lot of people were worried about this
because none of the other games had
co-op how is this gonna affect the game
is it gonna make it not so great is it
gonna be like Resident Evil 0 where you
can kind of control one person then they
gotta go off and you control the other
person then they go off or is it gonna
be forced co-op where they're always
there throughout the entire game right
next to you good news for people who
don't want to do that you can actually
choose to play the entire game on solo
campaign and never have to worry about
that ever which is what I did because I
played the first two that way and I
played this one that way so I can't
really review much about the coop so if
you weren't interested in playing co-op
then you can actually place the little
campaign but if you want to you can
invite a friend online or play with one
of your friends in real life which is
pretty cool now one thing I definitely
like about this game more than the first
two was the character of Isaac I always
enjoy him in the first two he was fun in
the first game he didn't even say
anything and you only saw his face once
and the second game you got to know him
more but in this game he really felt
like a human I gotta say he really felt
like a person you got more attached to
him and you really started to care for
the guy and one of the things that made
him more entertaining was his
familiarity with the events and the
creatures like he kept popping jokes
like oh yeah seen that before oh boy
this is one scene where there's this
regenerating creature and if you
remember anything about Dead Space 2
there's a freaking thing that just
follows you throughout the entire like
last third of the game every time you
shoot off its limbs just grows and right
back and keeps following you and it's
like the most unnerving thing in the
entire game aside from sticking
needle in Isaac's eye which was pretty
intense which makes me not understand
why people complain about the whole
action-oriented thing I thought the
games were pretty horrific actually
myself sticking a needle in your eye
yeah that's that's pretty horrifying
what was I saying
oh yeah in the game he encounters
another regenerating creature and this
guy shouts it's regenerating how are you
gonna kill it nice it just goes I'm not
and runs away that was like that is
awesome they really made Isaac a good
entertaining character in this game now
there was one part in the game where I
encountered a pretty serious glitch
there's this scene where you have a
cutscene and there's two characters
talking now what's supposed to happen
after that cutscene is you get ambushed
by these religious cultists that start
firing at you what happened to me once
in a game though is it somehow mixed
that up during the cutscene that
religious cultists started firing at you
so Isaac is just sitting there talking
to this guy being systematically
dismembered by the end of the cutscene
he was just two legs standing there and
as soon as the cutscene ended you just
fall over dead and I was like please
tell me that's not actually what the
game's supposed to do right now it
restarted from the last checkpoint and
didn't happen again but it may happen to
you I don't know did anyone else have
that experience no as I said the story
elements of this game aren't the most
impressive thing it wasn't even like
that in the first two the main villain
is very underdeveloped he's just kind of
there and has a big master scheme and
you had to save earth and all that stuff
and there's a damsel in distress of
course but the reason you play these
games is for the sheer visceral
entertainment of dismembering a whole
bunch of giant bug creatures that are
coming after you it's one of those games
where there are certain moments of the
game that are so challenging and when
you finally do surmount those challenges
it's like actually pretty invigorating
now I can see a complaint that some
people may have with this game and I'm
not gonna spoil it for you but at times
the game feels a little Mass Effect 3
ish and a lot of people are disappointed
with Mass Effect 3 there are certain
elements of this game that reminded me
of that and I can see that a lot of
people may play this game and be like
really okay I thought the way they chose
to take this game it was handled well I
can see them making a dead space floor
and I can see myself playing a dead
space board but I can't see how people
might think that it was ground they've
already walked on before the game
developers visceral games did a really
good job of this game it looks
incredible it sounds amazing
the voice acting is very good the sound
effects are great and overall it's just
a really fun game with good gameplay if
you chose to play it on co-op I'd really
be interested in what your thoughts were
I'm gonna give Dead Space 3 9 out of 10
thanks a lot for watching my first
official new release video game
review guys I'm gonna be getting aliens
colonial marines today it comes out
today hopefully I'll have that review
for you very soon also I'm gonna be
going to my buddy John the flick picks
house when it gets a little bit warmer
he started a video game channel called
flick video games I'm gonna be going to
his house and we're gonna do a couple of
video game related videos together I
hope you guys check out his channel it's
gonna be fun
we're probably just gonna do game play
games where we make jokes and talk while
we play the game which might be
entertaining for you I hope I don't know
but I left a link for his channel in the
description I hope you go check out his
channel he has some fun gameplay videos
for Call of Duty hope you enjoy it as
always guys thanks a lot for watching
and I'll be back very soon with my
review for aliens colonial Marines
hope you enjoyed this first video game
review and as always if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
my next
[Music]